avec nous Marielle de cernayez tête de
liste centriste pour l'Île-de-France
pour l'élection européenne de dimanche
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
invités de preuve par 3 que vous propose
publique Sénat en association avec lifep
Dailymotion nous sommes donc dans la
dernière ligne droite avant le scrutin
qui ne passionne pas l'opinion forte
abstention redoutée poussée à annoncer
des parties eurosceptiques voire euro
destructeur mais cela n'entend en rien
bien sûr votre foi dans l'Union va
renforce peut-être même peut-être et
avec moi ce soir Déborah Claude de l'AFP
et Perrine ternaux de Public Sénat mais
avant même les résultats de dimanche
soir est-ce que vous vous estimez
enregistrer en fait déjà un échec marial
de Cernay avec l'indifférence des
électeurs
c'est pas bon pour l'Europe c'est pas
bon pour la France parce que c'est
simple dans le monde qui est séduit dans
lequel on vit aujourd'hui avec les
dangers qui sont on voit une guerre
civile en Ukraine on voit la
déstabilisation en Afrique ou à la Chine
qui est passée devant les États-Unis on
a vitalement besoin mais la somme que je
parle c'est la différence à l'Europe j'y
arrive la seule question c'est de savoir
si on veut une Europe plus unie ou une
Europe moins unie ce qu'on veut une
Europe plus forte ou une Europe moins
forte moi je vous dis qu'évidemment il
faut qu'on ait une robe plus unie plus
forte et donc plus politique et plus
démocratique et c'est ça l'enjeu de
l'élection du 25 mai il y a un échec
peut-être plus important encore que
l'indifférence des électeurs c'est
finalement leur défiance et même on le
voit dans les sondages le rejet
aujourd'hui de l'Union européenne non je
ne suis pas d'accord il y a des
inquiétudes des interrogations
d'ailleurs il y en a aussi par rapport à
la démocratie nationale parce que au
fond il y a de moins en moins de votants
à chaque élection chez nous en France
c'est donc une double défiance vis-à-vis
des institutions nationales et puis
vis-à-vis des institutions européennes
et en même temps nous savons bien que
bah il va falloir évidemment continuer
la construction de cette Europe parce
qu'on en a vitalement besoin alors il
faut apporter des réponses concrètes il
faut apporter des solutions concrètes il
faut arrêter de nous balancer tous les
jours que tout est de la faute de
l'Europe depuis 30 ans dans ce pays
l'Europe est un bouc émissaire
extrêmement facile et donc ça empêche
quoi de voir nos propres difficultés à
nous Français ça empêche puisqu'on les
regarde pas de les régler et donc ça
fait 30 ans qu'on a toujours les mêmes
difficultés en France et ça empêche au
fond de recentrer l'Europe sur
l'essentiel l'essentiel pour moi c'est
quoi c'est la croissance et c'est
l'emploi on a besoin d'une Europe qui
soit un plus mais pas au rendez-vous en
France mais ils le sont dans certains
pays de la zone euro mais l'Europe doit
faire évidemment beaucoup plus vous
dites qu'on en a vitalement besoin de
l'Europe aujourd'hui mais alors que
répondez-vous au 67 % de Français pour
qui il faudrait en fait renforcer les
pouvoirs de décision de la France face
aux grandes difficultés du moment même
si ça limite les pouvoirs de l'Union
l'Union c'est pas l'Europe c'est pas
autre chose que nous et donc je leur dis
vous voulez plus de pouvoir ça veut dire
que vous voulez plus de politique et de
ce point de vue là ils ont raison on a
besoin d'avoir dans le monde qui est le
nôtre des leviers de pouvoir on a besoin
d'avoir des leviers on a besoin d'avoir
on a besoin d'avoir des leviers de
pouvoir dans notre ville dans notre
région dans notre État français et on a
besoin que l'Europe se recentre sur
l'essentiel c'est ça au fond à peu près
la vision du monde qu'on doit défendre
pour demain une campagne on va parler de
votre projet bien sûr mais une campagne
se fait aussi sur un bilan quel bilan
positif là vous vous pourriez dresser de
ces dernières années bah écoutez
l'Europe c'est évidemment va tous le
dire Airbus et des magnifiques
réalisations et en même temps c'est plus
que ça moi je suis très attachée à
l'idée même de l'Europe à l'idée
européenne parce que c'est une idée au
fond de dépassement de dépassement des
nationalistes regardez ce qui se passe
en Russie c'est le retour du
nationalisme moi j'ai pas du tout envie
de connaître ça pour nos pays et pour
nos États membres c'est une idée de
dépassement des égoïsmes nationaux on a
besoin de plus de solidarité c'est ça au
fond l'idée européenne je crois que
c'est une idée qui vaut d'ailleurs pas
seulement pour l'Europe mais
probablement pour le monde qui nous
entoure aussi mais malheureusement pour
la majorité des Français l'Europe c'est
synonyme de crise de stérilité
tout le monde participe que l'Europe
mais l'Europe ça n'est rien d'autre que
nous c'est pas une affaire de politique
étrangère l'Europe nous formons l'Europe
nous sommes l'Europe la France est au
fond un des piliers
de cette Europe donc faut peut-être
qu'on s'interroge sur la manière d'abord
dont nous gouvernons dans notre propre
pays puis la somme de décennie et sur la
manière dont nous n'assumons pas notre
choix européen et sur la manière dont
nos démocraties nationales l'Assemblée
le Sénat au fond ne participe pas des
décisions qui sont des décisions
collectives européennes la démocratie
nationale elle doit s'impliquer
davantage dans la démocratie européenne
il y a au fond une fracture entre les
peuples et l'idée comme ça des
institutions qui apparaissent lointaine
moi je crois que une des réponses pour
moi un des mandats qu'on doit donner à
nos gouvernants européens et au prochain
Parlement européen c'est de construire
cette démocratie européenne dont on a
vraiment besoin à faire valoir en la
matière et c'est vrai que l'Europe en a
besoin le slogan du Front national c'est
non à Bruxelles oui à la France vous
l'avez noté et c'est vrai que pour
beaucoup de Français là encore excusez
moi barrière de sarnaise mais Bruxelles
est synonyme d'impuissance de
technocratie envahissante pour vous
Bruxelles est synonyme de quoi la
commission c'est quoi c'est une
institution qui doit normalement être
aux ordres des politiques on va prendre
un exemple traité transatlantique dans
tout le monde parle en ce moment et tout
le monde dit
qu'est-ce qu'a inventé Bruxelles
qu'est-ce qu'un inventé l'Europe elle a
rien inventé du tout Bruxelles a rien
inventé du tout les chefs d'État de
gouvernement donc Monsieur Hollande ça
pourrait être d'ailleurs quelqu'un
d'autre il y a ça peut être Sarkozy ça
peut être Chirac avant il a fait quoi en
juin dernier il a donné un mandat à la
Commission pour aller négocier en son
nom avec les Américains un accord de
libre-échange est-ce qu'il y a eu un
débat au Sénat avant est-ce qu'il y a eu
un débat l'Assemblée nationale avant
est-ce qu'il y a une conférence de
presse de François Hollande pour
expliquer que on y allait avoir au fond
des perspectives et c'était important de
connaître les lignes rouges de prendre
en compte la défense des intérêts des
Français
non et donc vous voyez bien que la
responsabilité française
c'est très important dans le processus
de décision je veux vous rappeler que
pas une décision ne se prend à Bruxelles
qui n'était validée par la France disons
les choses en face la théorie du bouc
émissaire c'est hyper simple ça permet
d'aller vite mais voyez le traité
transatlantique c'est gouvernement si
François Hollande si il Parlement avait
joué son rôle et bah au fond ils
auraient sécurisé les Français parce
qu'ils auraient pris en compte les
attentes des Français les exigences des
Français et c'était normal de le faire
avant l'ouverture même des négociations
ça n'a pas été fait non plus
reconnaissez-le c'est la formation la
transparence des négociations alors je
sais que c'est difficile tournez-vous
vers vos gouvernants
n'a aucune responsabilité l'assemblée
non plus François Hollande non plus
et vous l'avez été bossé là vous avez eu
un débat non donc je vous dis qu'il y a
un déficit de débat européen vous savez
que par exemple quand il y a des débats
à Strasbourg aller allons-y la première
chaîne allemande elle retransmet tous
les tous les débats vous êtes une chaîne
parlementaire vous retransmettez tous
les débats des sessions de Strasbourg
la première chaîne allemande elle le
fait tous les jours alors la démocratie
européenne ça doit évidemment on doit
pousser à sa tante de changement nos
institutions pour moi on doit élire
demain après-demain un président ou une
présidente de l'Union on doit clarifier
rendre plus lisible dans institutions
mais chacun a sa part de responsabilité
dans tout cela
viennent de reprendre d'ailleurs aux
États-Unis c'était lundi on agite
beaucoup de peur beaucoup de fantasmes
sur l'environnement sur la sécurité
sanitaire de nos aliments etc est-ce que
pour vous
on fait peur volontairement à l'opinion
il y a plusieurs est-ce que cet accord
de libre-échange qui va qui veut essayer
de favoriser le commerce sera vraiment
utile pour les Européens moi c'est une
question que je me pose donc pour
l'instant je regarde et après je me dis
j'ai trois grandes questions la première
question c'est celle de la démocratie
donc oui on aurait mieux fait de parler
du mandat avant et de savoir quels
étaient les intérêts vitaux des
Européens avant de donner un mandat à la
Commission et ça c'est notre
gouvernement français qui n'a pas fait
son boulot ça c'est le premier point
deuxième point sur la question du
contenu c'est la question qu'on appelle
des normes c'est à dire des standards au
fond qui sont les nôtres à nous
Européens on a des normes on a des
normes de très très grandes qualités en
Europe en matière environnementale ou
sanitaire ou social certains vous diront
on a des normes beaucoup trop exigeantes
je ne le crois pas je pense que c'est
une avancée pour les Européens je pense
que c'est une protection pour les
Européens mais toute la question de ce
futur négociation ça va être et ce qu'on
conserve cette qualité de norme ou
est-ce qu'on les rabaisse évidemment il
faut pas les rabaisser il faut les
conserver la possibilité de donner un
mandat plus précis que ce qui n'a été
fait et évidemment à terme de dire non
pas seulement pas le mot européen le
Parlement européen les parlements
nationaux relisant le et le gouvernement
français alors les ténors ont été assez
peu audible durant cette campagne
Marielle de sarnaise je vois mon
François Hollande Alain Juppé François
Fillon ont défendu la grande idée
européenne et vous-même dans votre livre
par exemple vous faites référence à
mitterrandis Giscard c'est incroyable
non Giscard c'est bien parce qu'on n'est
pas loin du 19 mai hier on était on a
fêté le 40 ans les 40e anniversaire de
1974 et on s'est retrouvé à quelques-uns
et c'était bien agréable je vais vous
dire chez les présidents de la
République française je considère que
les deux présidents de la République
française qui ont eu une vision de
l'Europe c'est effectivement Valéry
gaglestin et François Mitterrand et que
depuis franchement c'est plus tout à
fait au rendez-vous on a eu des
présidents plus ou moins européens je
peux pas dire qu'il ne le soit pas
européen mais entre être européens
s'accommoder de l'Europe et puis porter
une vision une vision de l'Europe et une
vision de ce que la France attend
l'Europe vous voyez bien qu'il y a une
immense différence
ça c'est pas terrible alors dimanche se
joue également le remplacement de José
Manuel Barroso après 10 ans à la tête de
la Commission européenne et il partait
le bilan là le bilan global de l'Europe
depuis cette émission
comme le bouc émissaire mais quel bilan
et vous vous tirez
la première fois ni la deuxième fois
j'ai un candidat qui s'appelle giver
hochtadt qui est le candidat de mon
groupe qui est le groupe parlementaire
du centre au Parlement européen qui est
l'ancien Premier ministre belge disant
Premier ministre belge ça apprend le
consensus c'est important de savoir
gouverner la Belgique il était pressenti
à 10 ans pour être président de la
commission et puis il a été rayé vous
savez pourquoi parce qu'il était trop
européen et bien je trouve que ce serait
pas mal 10 années après peut-être de le
nommer mais au fond qu'est-ce qui s'est
passé les chefs d'État est gouvernement
dès qu'il voit quelqu'un qui peut
éventuellement leur faire un peu d'ombre
dès qu'il voit quelqu'un on va dire de
talentueux d'énergie expérimenté de comp
non non non ça peut être dangereux pour
nous et donc c'est évidemment pas un bon
système là pour la première fois les
partis politiques européens ont pré
désigné un candidat à la présidence de
la commission notre candidat pour le
centre c'est give & je pense que
vraiment là avec lui l'Europe avancerait
et que les citoyens s'y retrouveraient
beaucoup mieux et c'est vraiment la
hauteur
oui mais comme on nous raconte à
longueur de journée des bêtises
c'est-à-dire le Parti socialiste vous
explique vous allez voir il y aura un
Parlement européen de gauche l'UMP vous
Parlement européen de droite et que l'un
et l'autre raconte des carambistouilles
mensonges disent des choses absolument
il débarque tout droit de Bruxelles et
il espère bien convaincre les Français
give et rochta était le candidat des
centres à la Commission européenne en
campagne dans un pays où les
eurosceptiques ont la cote à gauche
comme à droite c'est ce qu'on voit
partout en Europe c'est que les parties
classiques coûtent derrière les
eurosceptiques c'est l'hypocrisie mais
plutôt le l'opportunisme politique on
pense voilà courir derrière Marine Le
Pen ou Mélenchon ça va aider à garder
notre force politique et ça c'est une
c'est une grande erreur certes le centre
affiche un programme tourné vers le roi
en proposant par exemple l'élection d'un
président européen au suffrage universel
une stratégie économique et commerciale
comme un y compris en matière de
fiscalité l'UDI modem suggère également
de construire les bases d'un droit du
travail européen ou encore une
régulation commune de l'immigration avec
la création d'une police des frontières
européennes pas question pour autant de
jouer les portes étendards absolus de
Bruxelles du côté des Verts on assume la
ligne fédéraliste du coup pour ce
sénateur les centristes tiendraient un
double discours et leur programme en
serait la preuve j'ai rien trouvé sur
l'Europe fédérale je suis désolé le mot
est occulté c'est reconnu d'ailleurs
dans une interview par Madame de
sarnaise qui dit effectivement nous
avons pas utilisé le mot Europe fédéral
alors quand Daniel Cohn-Bendit parle de
fédéralisme Guy hofstadt lui préfère le
terme d'intégrationnisme pour ne pas
paraître européen les mots ont un sens
et pour cause selon un sondage paru ce
dimanche près de la moitié des Français
se diraient déçus de la construction
européenne résultant en ce moment les
fédéralistes aurait plutôt tendance à
raser les murs
voilà donc c'est parfois difficile de
s'assumer totalement européen sur le
plan sémantique on va en parler hein
pour une Europe intégrée plus unis plus
forte on peut rester 2 secondes sur le
mot fédéralisme
alors je vous écoute je réserve mon sur
le terrain
moi je ne rase pas les murs
c'est un mot qui a un double sens et
donc comme tous les mots à double sens
il est un peu piégent en France le mot
fédéralisme fédéral il est vécu comme ah
ils veulent un super état européen à
Bruxelles alors moi je veux pas du tout
un super état ni à Bruxelles et
d'ailleurs à Paris je trouve que l'État
devrait mieux faire et probablement un
peu moins et c'est pareil pour Bruxelles
et c'est pareil pour Paris et puis le
fédéralisme en Allemagne c'est tout le
contraire c'est ce qu'on appelle le
principe de subsidiarité c'est à dire
que tout ce qui peut être fait au niveau
local au plus près du citoyen est fait
au plus près du citoyen quand c'est
pertinent et bien moi c'est ça ma vision
de l'Europe et donc vous voyez que c'est
un mot qui est à double sens et qui est
un peu piéger
alors fédéralisme là on a vu Guy
feroffstett qui est en campagne avec
vous donc le modem et l'UDI on le
rappelle quand même qu'ils sont
rassemblés pour ces élections dans les
sondages vous oscillez entre 8 et 10%
vous dépassez pas les 10% pour l'instant
est-ce que c'est une déception pour vous
de ne pas encore accrocher on sait que
c'est les dans les derniers jours vous
le dites vous-même c'est la dernière
semaine que ça va se faire vous comptez
grappiller encore qu'on a passé beaucoup
de temps dans cette pré campagne sous
les questions de l'extrême de
l'extrémisme et que je regrette qu'on
n'est pas passé plus de temps sur la
question de l'Europe et de l'avenir de
l'Europe parce que c'est ça la question
pour ceux qui vont aller voter le 25 mai
et donc j'espère ce fameux cette
émission aidant et d'autres que enfin
dans les derniers jours de campagne on
pose la question avec le débattement
autour de quelle Europe veut-on pour
faire quoi recentrer sur quoi qu'on
puisse mettre des propositions sur la
table nous nous avons nous défendons une
idée juste c'est l'idée que dans le
monde tel qu'il est il faut plutôt plus
d'union que moins d'union et que le
chacun pour soi et donc c'est une idée
juste nous avons un certain nombre de
proposition veut recentrer l'Europe sur
ce que j'appelle l'essentiel la
croissance l'emploi j'espère qu'on va en
parler et puis la place dans le monde et
puis la place dans le monde parce que
c'est très très important en filigrane
c'est qu'on a trop parlé du Front
National et pas assez du fruit
clairement pas en filigrane je trouve
que ça ne tourne que autour du Front
National et des extrêmes et qu'on a donc
oublié au fond zapper le débat purement
européen sur l'avenir de leur retraité
du traité Atlantique on en parle il y a
quand même d'autres sujets qui viennent
sur le sur la table non non mais je vous
dis pas que dans cette émission
très globale vous voyez bien que cette
espèce de première partie de campagne
elle a plus tourné autour
malheureusement de ce qui représente
l'extrême
on l'a rappelé tout à l'heure dire que
de me taper les électeurs à donner une
nouvelle raclée au pouvoir exécutif et
François Hollande alors vous êtes très
choqué
c'est pas du tout mon approche de cette
élection je pense que on parle d'Europe
une fois tous les cinq ans je
souhaiterais qu'on en parle davantage
parce que c'est quand même notre horizon
le Grison naturel dans lequel s'inscrit
notre action et que moi je considère
qu'on doit voter sur la question du
projet européen au fond qu'est-ce que
c'est l'enjeu du 25 mai c'est quelle
Europe on choisit et quel parlementaire
européen compétent plutôt expérimenté
allant pour qu'il l'Europe n'est pas un
deuxième choix mais premier choix je dis
ça au passage c'est le cas de choix
qu'on a fait chez nous au centre nous
avons de formidables parlementaires de
formidable future parlementaire européen
c'est ça l'enjeu c'est d'envoyer au
Parlement européen des gens qui
représenteront les intérêts de la France
de l'Île-de-France pour notre
circonscription et puis de l'Europe
d'une manière générale parfois ne sont
pas connus sur le plan national et qui
du coup ils passent beaucoup de temps à
Strasbourg et à Bruxelles
si vous voulez je crois que nous au
centre on a cette clarté on a cette
cohérence on important cette idée juste
et j'espère bien que oui le score sera
au rendez-vous un score à deux chiffres
le meilleur possible le meilleur
possible pour continuer de crever
l'abcès sur le front national quand même
parce que voilà c'est vrai que dimanche
on va scruter ça de près même si c'est
un scrutin on risque d'avoir beaucoup de
d'abstention pour vous ça va changer
quelque chose si il est en tête par
rapport à l'UMP qu'est-ce que ça veut
qui est le moins d'abstention possible
je vois bien que MPS tout ça ça les
arrange assez bien ils veulent au fond
il faut l'accompagne sur des affaires
nationales françaises parce qu'ils sont
gênés aux alentours l'un comme l'autre
sur les questions de fond et sur les
questions européennes ceux qui sont pas
à gênés aux Antonio sur les questions
européennes comme nous au centre qui
sont clairs qui sont cohérents au fil du
temps au fond qui savons qu'il faut
poursuivre achevé par HP améliorer la
construction européenne elle nous
parlons d'Europe parce que justement il
y a pas de division chez nous et donc ça
c'est très important donc je souhaite
vraiment que tous les électeurs pour
qu'il l'idée même de construction
européenne est important et pour qu'il
cela fait sens chez eux se déplacent et
viennent voter le 25 mai c'était
extrêmement important ensuite vous posez
dimanche ensuite vous posez la question
sur le score du Front national c'est pas
pareil moi je viens de dire il faut que
les européens viennent s'exprimer
aujourd'hui on a eu des grands européens
qui sont exprimés on a eu par exemple le
PDG d'Airbus qui a fait une lettre à
tous ces salariés pour dire combien
l'Europe était une chance on a eu le
représentant des agriculteurs français
qui a fait la même chose la semaine
dernière c'est intéressant ce sont des
signes que je trouve très encourageants
soit le Front national moi je vous dis
quelque chose de très simple cette
élection c'est une élection à la
proportionnelle c'est la seule élection
où on peut exprimer clairement son choix
c'est la seule élection dans laquelle il
y ait du pluralisme parce que le mode de
scrutin français en particulier les
scrutin majoritaires sont discuta voilà
très bipolaire il y a du pluralisme
votez pour vos convictions votez au fond
pour l'idée que vous vous faites de
l'Europe pour les années qui viennent et
pour vos enfants c'est ça pour moi qui
compte boude plus beaucoup plus que tout
le reste que l'interprétation qui
pourrait être faite
les extrêmes oui mais parce que je veux
dire on passe notre temps à commenter
Madame Le Pen dans cette campagne et
bien vous les médias nous quelquefois
parce que vous nous posez les questions
les heures de passage des uns et des
autres qui sont multipliés par 10 ou par
20 bon ça va bien beaucoup de pas être
représenté dans les médias différents
alors moi je demande une chose c'est que
les derniers jours de campagne le débat
tourne autour de l'Europe et pas autour
de Madame Le Pen alors qu'est-ce que
vous proposez par exemple qu'est-ce que
vous dites aux électeurs aux Français
qui s'inquiètent aujourd'hui en raison
du chômage galopant du dumping social
qui existe à l'intérieur des frontières
de l'Union je leur dis une chose très
simple c'est qu'il faut mettre fin oui
bien sûr un agenda de la convergence
dans les cinq années qui viennent il
faut que les chefs d'État et
gouvernement acceptent de se mettre
autour de la table et de se dire qu'on
est obligé obligé de mettre fin aux
inégalités fiscales et sociales je vais
donner un exemple l'impôt sur les
sociétés vous savez qu'en Irlande
l'impôt sur les sociétés étaient à 12 et
demi pour cent un grand nombre de
grandes sociétés particulières
américaines ils sont basés parce que au
fond c'est l'optimisation fiscale et
puis en France on va avoir le même impôt
sur les sociétés à 33 % ou à 38 et donc
la convergence c'est quoi c'est de faire
monter le taux qui est en Irlande et de
faire baisser probablement le taux qui
est en soi libère un taux vers un taux
moyen sur les salaires par exemple
travailleur détachés c'est exactement la
même chose vous avez des travailleurs
détachés en Europe qui sont payés au
salaire du pays dans lequel il est ils
sont employés mais les charges sont
celles du pays d'où ils viennent et bien
nous proposons très quelque chose
d'extrêmement simple c'est de payer des
charges du pays dans lesquelles il
travaille et donc l'Europe des solutions
elle existe la question c'est la volonté
politique des uns et des autres en
particulier des chefs d'État de
gouvernement et c'est pour ça que je dis
que c'est important que les européens
viennent voter 25 mai parce qu'il faut
qu'ils obligent les chefs d'états
gouvernement à avancer sur cette Europe
qui soit plus politique plus efficace
vraiment au service de la croissance et
de l'emploi pour les Européens le
Premier ministre hier ou avant-hier je
crois dit l'Europe c'est la solution ou
manuel Valls vous êtes aussi d'accord
alors après il faut aller il faut aller
jusqu'au bout ça veut dire qu'il faut
arrêter de raconter en France que tout
ce qui va pas c'est l'Europe ça veut
dire qu'il faut tenir le même discours à
Paris et à Bruxelles ce qui n'est
absolument jamais le cas ça veut dire
qu'il faut arrêter de dire oh là là il
faut lutter contre la dette et le
déficit parce que Bruxelles nous y
oblige c'est stupide parce que c'est
faux même si Bruxelles n'existait pas il
faudrait qu'on lutte contre la dette et
le déficit il y a pas une famille
française qui sait qu'elle peut vivre
au-dessus de son niveau de vie c'est
exactement la même chose pour la France
mais cette Europe elle doit porter un
plus en matière de croissance par
exemple on a besoin d'une politique
industrielle européenne et l'affaire
d'Alstom elle est très intéressante de
ce point de vue là normalement le chef
d'État gouvernement aurait dû avoir une
vision stratégique s'ils étaient un peu
visionnaires et se dire tiens il y a
Alstom tiens yassimens et ben peut-être
si on avait la volonté politique de
faire coopérer ces deux entreprises
magnifiques on aurait deux entreprises
de taille mondiale une pour tout ce qui
est ferroviaire TGV et une pour tout ce
qui est énergie et c'est ça moi que je
veux c'est une Europe qui fait de la
stratégie c'est une robe qui défend
d'une vision
de temps en temps des protections vous
en avez parlé sur le plan social il y a
un instant Maria de sarnaise mais votre
candidat donc guidé au chat il est
partisan lui libéralisation accrue il
veut parachever le grand marché
de l'énergie de la téléphonie
ça veut dire politique commune de
l'énergie est-ce qu'on a besoin d'une
politique commune de l'énergie la
réponse est oui est-ce qu'on peut
continuer à dépendre éternellement soit
d'un côté des émirats soit de l'autre
côté de la Russie de Monsieur Poutine et
bien non qu'est-ce qu'il a dit ce matin
dans une radio il a dit par exemple on
produit de l'énergie solaire en Espagne
on peut pas l'acheminer dans un autre
pays de l'Union européenne c'est ça que
nous voulons c'est faire des choses de
bon sens avec au fond qu'on gagne notre
indépendance énergétique et même notre
autosuffisance et ça ce serait sacrément
intéressant pour le rendre mais je viens
de vous répondre exactement avec
l'exemple concret qu'on a utilisé qu'il
a utilisé ce matin
vous êtes très attaché à la
démocratisation
vous prenez l'élection suffrage
universelle d'un président là il y a
cinq candidats en lice pour la
présidence de la commission s'il sort
quelqu'un d'autre du chapeau qu'est-ce
que quelle sera l'attitude du Parlement
comment ça va se passer parce que cette
hypothèse n'est pas complètement levée
Jacques Delors a dit il y a deux jours
je crois on ne pourra pas aller au clash
institutionnel mais cette rumeur qui qui
court écoutez je crois que si les chefs
d'État gouvernement ne comprennent pas
que la question numéro 1 en Europe c'est
pas celle temps de son efficacité de
tout ça très important mais la première
question c'est celle de la démocratie et
au fond qu'est-ce qui sait qu'est-ce qui
s'est passé entre les peuples et
l'Europe ben c'est qu'ils ont eu le
sentiment les citoyens que les décisions
se prenaient sans eux d'ailleurs c'est
souvent la même chose dans leur pays
donc c'est une défiance qui s'accumule
et donc si les chefs d'État du
gouvernement ne prennent pas conscience
de ça c'est que franchement il voit rien
du tout et donc il y a une urgence en
Europe la première
urgence européenne c'est d'avancer vers
plus de démocratie et bien plus de
démocratie c'est par exemple de choisir
effectivement un de ceux qui sont
candidats celui qui est au centre là du
verre il me plaît parce que c'est celui
qui peut
travailler ensemble au fond la famille
des conservateurs que Jean-Claude
Juncker représente et la famille des
socialistes que marketing représente
que nous sommes le groupe central qui
faisons quelquefois les différences de
majorité justement au parlementaire donc
on a un rôle très important parmi les
gens de qualité et européens que vous
pourriez avec qui vous pourriez
travailler Pierre Moscovici c'est une
bonne idée pour demander à François
Hollande moi je lui demande quelque
chose à François Hollande déjà c'est que
il nomme un homme et une femme comme ça
on pourra choisir et on aura peut-être
la parité au sein de la commission parce
que c'est aussi une question importante
pour l'instant c'est mal parti une
ultime question
non non mais plus franco-française sur
votre alliance
udi modem est-ce que effectivement si
vous faites un score moyen voir médiocre
dimanche d'abord je pense que ça va
remettre en cause avec un score à deux
chiffres et des députés compétents élus
je pense que ça sera quelque chose de
bien dans les temps dans lesquels nous
sommes et donc je pense que c'est ça je
pense que c'est ça qui va se passer et
ensuite notre alliance
notre alliance elle doit évidemment
perdurer si on était satisfait de la vie
politique française telle qu'elle se
déroule depuis 30 ans on n'aurait pas
fait se rapprochement des centres entre
Jean-Louis d'un côté et François de
l'autre on se restait chacun séparé dans
notre petite chapelle ceci n'a plus de
sens on a besoin de changer la vie
politique française et pour ça on a
besoin qui est une offre nouvelle au
centre de la vie politique française et
pour cela il faut peser et pour peser il
faut être unique c'est comme pour
l'Europe première étape donc dimanche
prochain merci Deborah internault arrive
et on va se poser la question suivante
est-ce que François Hollande regarde
plus que jamais les centristes et de
rappeler votre positionnement comme une
possible force d'appoint la question
s'adresse d'ailleurs particulièrement à
vous marier de Cernay parce que je me
souviens des contacts étroits que vous
aviez noué avec le Parti socialiste je
me suis fait une réunion à 10 jours
donc je ne suis pas socialiste
le vote pour François Hollande c'est le
choix que je fais quand François Bayrou
annonce dans l'entre-deux tours 2012
qu'il vote associaliste c'est un choc
dans l'univers centriste
traditionnellement plus proche de la
droite très vite il laisse entendre en
privé qu'il est disponible pour intégrer
le gouvernement mais la proposition ne
viendra jamais après 2012 et son score
de 9%
et puis les élections législatives ou
lui perd son siège il y a plus que Jean
alors la salle qui est député vous
faites quoi avec un député est-ce que
François Hollande il a envie de s'allier
avec un parti qui a un député
c'est-à-dire qui lui sert à rien mais
deux ans plus tard face à l'impopularité
présidentielle certains au sein d'une
majorité fragilisée regrette ce choix je
pense qu'on aurait pu non pas pratiquer
l'ouverture mais faire comme on l'avait
fait par le passé comme l'avait fait
Mitterrand ou rencard à une époque
essayer de rechercher quelques personnes
du centre capables capables d'évoluer
sur un certain nombre de dossiers
dossiers de sociétés je vous l'ai dit
nous aussi le dossier économique sur
lesquels les centrices sont très
réalistes pour pouvoir avancer un peu
de fait la politique menée par François
Hollande depuis le virage
social-démocratique il y a six mois
reprend des mesures prônées depuis des
années par les centristes comme la
réforme territoriale ou le pacte de
responsabilité une proximité qui n'est
pourtant assumée ni par le chef de
l'État soucieux de ménager l'algorge de
son parti ni par les centrices pour nous
François Hollande aujourd'hui ne fait
absolument pas une politique du centre
il fait absolument pas la politique des
propositions de François Bayrou de temps
en temps il va un petit peu dans cette
direction l'échec est tellement fort
depuis deux ans que il y a quelques
mesures de bon sens qui sont en phase
avec ce que nous disons mais on est très
très loin d'éléments de politique proche
le choix est donc fait d'un
rapprochement avec la droite comme à Pau
ou François Bayrou remporte la mairie
avec le soutien affiché d'Alain Juppé
2017 il se disent ben nous on veut bien
enfin c'est de la stratégie électorale
d'ailleurs pourquoi Salier avec des
perdants autant rester avec les gagnants
officiellement les centristes adoptent
donc la posture d'une opposition dite
constructive prête à voter au coup par
coup certaines mesures proches de ces
idées
voilà Marielle Sarnez pour la dernière
partie d'émission on va un peu moins
parler d'Europe c'est comme ça avec
Perrine Tano qui nous a rejoint
Michel bonsoir politique nationale on
vient d'entendre Robert Rochefort avec
qui vous travaillez qui n'est pas
d'accord le gouvernement ne fait pas la
politique du centre c'est aussi votre
opinion si votre question c'est ce que
vous aviez dit dans la présentation
est-ce que le centre à vocation servir
de force d'appoint au gouvernement et la
majorité la réponse est non et c'est
extrêmement clair non en aucune façon ni
aujourd'hui les deux mains ni
après-demain c'est pas comme ça qu'on
fait les choses parce que c'est pas
comme ça qu'on fait les choses en
démocratie
remplacer à remplacer un bout de la
majorité qui ne serait plus là et que il
ne soutiendrait plus ça ce genre de truc
ça ne peut pas fonctionner après il y a
une deuxième chose donc je vous ai dit
clairement pour la majorité parce qu'il
faut être clair après il y a une
deuxième chose est-ce que si quelques
mesures prises dans le bon sens on peut
effectivement par nos votes ne pas y
être hostile on n'a pas vocation à être
complètement stupide on n'a pas vocation
avec complètement stupide et donc une
opposition constructive c'est une
opposition qui est en mesure de regarder
si quelquefois des initiatives ont dans
le bon sens pourquoi le groupe centriste
c'est abstenu justement sur le plan de
Manuel Valls il s'est abstenu qu'on a
signal positif parce qu'il trouvait que
ça allait dans le bon sens voilà ça
c'est une attitude au fond assez civile
une opposition qui est là exigeante et
qui en même temps quand le gouvernement
va dans le sens de ce qu'elle souhaite
depuis des années bah du plus tôt bah
écoutez ce pas inintéressant mais moi je
dis ça avec prudence parce que toutes
les réformes annoncées pack de
responsabilité réforme des collectivités
territoriales j'attends vraiment de voir
économie de 50 milliards j'attends
vraiment de se dire que dans une période
économique difficile en situation de
crise il puisse y avoir des alliances
qui se nouent entre des parties qui
n'ont peut-être pas tout à fait
l'habitude de travailler ça fait 20 ans
complet pour que le déplacement du pays
se fasse par un contrat directement et
clairement devant les Français avec
plusieurs forces politiques comme ce que
shreder a fait en Allemagne ce
qu'aujourd'hui Angela Merkel fait donc
moi vous prêchez une convaincue
simplement un les institutions de la
Cinquième République aujourd'hui ne le
permettent pas et deuxièmement les
attitudes des uns et des autres ne l'ont
pas rendu possible c'est comme ça
qu'il faut parler de la politique je
crois pas
je ne ressens pas de cette façon là
je me souviens de lui sur ce plateau il
y a deux ans après l'élection de
François Hollande il tendait quand même
la main à l'actuel majorité et pourtant
il a fait des propositions le tournant
le virage social-démocrate n'avait pas
encore eu lieu d'abord vous faites tous
rigoler avec le journal le tournant
social-démocrate on épingle à cheveux
tout ce que vous voulez moi pour
l'instant il y a aucun acte il y a rien
de précis non mais ça m'amuse parce que
tout le monde c'est une ritournelle
comme ça
mais tant mieux si François Hollande est
décidé enfin à agir et à agir je dis
agir pas parler dans le bon sens et dans
la bonne direction tant mieux la
question c'est est-ce qu'il va vraiment
le faire est-ce que c'est pas un peu
trop tard après je vous ai dit si des
textes vont dans le bon sens au fond un
parlement vous le savez bien ça devrait
être là pour ça je veux dire
l'opposition devrait pas être
systématiquement compte parce qu'elle
est opposante à la majorité dans une
démocratie intelligente on essaye de
lire les textes avant d'émettre une
opinion et si ces textes vont dans le
bon sens on le dit et on le dira et ça y
a rien de plus normal et si vite que ce
genre d'attitude que la politique menée
par François Hollande et plus proche des
idées de François Valéron que celle de
Nicolas Sarkozy non non je ne au jour
d'aujourd'hui au jour d'aujourd'hui ça
fait six mois que l'on dit je fais un
virage je fais un virage je tourne je
tourne je tourne je ne sais pas où sont
les 50 milliards d'économies je ne sais
pas comment en plus en rendant de
l'argent donc on rebaisse les impôts et
on rembourse la dette et en même temps
on donne 30 milliards aux entreprises et
comment on fait tout ça en même temps
moi je ne le sais toujours pas donc à la
règle aucune participation par exemple
la gouvernement possible on a bien
compris vraiment pas du tout dans le but
ou que qu'on se fixe il ne peut pas y
avoir de changement de majorité sans
retourner aux urnes disons les choses
telles que c'est c'est ça la démocratie
on a diffusé sur Public Sénat dimanche
dernier le grand meeting des centristes
pour les élections européennes avec
notamment le message adressé par
Jean-Louis Borloo est-ce que vous pensez
définitif le fait qu'il est fermé la
porte à tout retour pour lui en
politique le crois pas mais mais bon
c'est vraiment là-dessus c'est oui bien
sûr mais c'est sa grande liberté et
c'est vraiment à lui de le dire ça a été
ces mots dimanche
après ce que ces mots sont définitifs
est-ce que ceci évoluera quand il ira
mieux on verra on peut l'espérer donc ça
veut dire que pour un carnet le centre
en 2017 il n'en reste plus qu'un
finalement au centre c'est François il y
a une élection présidentielle très bien
européenne si ça vous ennuie pas on va
d'abord essayer de voir comment le pays
peut ou pas prendre le chemin du
changement du redressement dans les
années qui viennent parce que c'est
quand même ça qui est important et je
vais vous dire moi je fais de la
politique vraiment je suis engagé mais
ça n'est plus possible d'être dans cette
république
omnibuée et pourtant vraiment j'ai fait
des campagnes présidentielles avec
François Bayrou vraiment et ça m'a plu
j'ai aimé ça vous aurez aimé ça je vous
le dis vraiment mais on ne peut pas être
omnibulé par l'élection présidentielle
d'un mandat comme ça à l'autre parce que
ça vous empêche quoi non mais ça vous
empêche de regarder les problèmes
d'aujourd'hui ça vous empêche de
chercher les bonnes réponses aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous pourriez envisager qu'il
n'y ait pas de candidat du centre cette
sélection
sera la France en 3 ans qui sait et ce
qui va se passer est-ce que François
Hollande va soumettre à un homme ce que
nous appelons nos vœux c'est-à-dire une
moralisation de la vie publique ce que
nous demandons avec François Bayeux
depuis deux ans qui passe par je vais
pas me rendre populaire au Sénat ni à
l'assemblée par une réduction du nombre
de députés par une réduction du nombre
de sénateurs par un changement du mode
de scrutin par la fin des micro parties
par une vraie moralisation de la vie
publique avec une nouvelle architecture
qui dessinerait nos orientations en
matière d'institutions locales et ce qui
va c'est ce qu'on lui demande de faire
mais c'est ce qu'on lui demande de faire
qu'il soumettent à référendum une vraie
étape de moralisation de la vie publique
est-ce que ça aidera beaucoup comme on
parle de référendum la droite l'UMP
demande un réfleir un référendum sur
toute la réforme de la décentralisation
est-ce que c'est aussi votre position
soit les élus sont prêts à voter des
réformes qui les mettent même en cause
j'en serais très heureuse j'en suis pas
sûr si c'est pas le cas le recours au
peuple me semble la bonne voie
Marielle de sarnasse de déçu vous êtes
aussi élu au Conseil de Paris il y a eu
la première réunion hier et aujourd'hui
de la nouvelle de ce nouveau Conseil de
Paris avec ami dalgo à la tête de Paris
pardon première séance et avec une
délibération un petit peu difficile
autour du maire honoraire Bertrand
Delanoë qui va donc bénéficier d'un
bureau et d'une secrétaire à l'hôtel de
ville de Paris vous avez voté pour vous
avez voté contre quel est votre position
j'étais hier au débat sur le logement
qui me semble je vous dis entre les deux
débats il y a pas photo il y en a un qui
est très important je vous le dis qui
est très important qui est quelle
stratégie pour faire du logement demain
à Paris pour les classes intermédiaires
et un que je trouve absolument
anecdotique je ne pense pas que j'aurai
voté pour pas légitime selon vous que
Bertrand Delanoë
Yves poto dit Borgo élu
udi à Paris a voté pour et c'est à mes
amis
mais je pense que c'est vraiment un
sujet sur lequel chacun peut avoir son
avis mais qui n'est quand même pas si
majeur que cela et elle est rentrée dans
le rôle de mère de Paris selon vous pour
la première séance je vais dire non pas
encore ça c'est un peu normal non mais
je ne vous dis pas le contraire me poser
une question je vous réponds vous
estimez qu'elle va être très prisonnière
de cette turbulents alliés les
communistes et les écologistes ça va
être difficile pour penser beaucoup plus
que pour Bertrand Delanoë majorité
difficile et ça sera probablement oui
plus difficile pour elle que pour
Bertrand Delanoë je le crois Nathalie
Kosciusko-Morizet avec qui vous avez
fait campagne à Paris affiche sa
priorité notamment pour la rentrée
scolaire en septembre prochain avec
l'aménagement des rythmes scolaires
c'est aussi votre priorité à vous vous
partagez cet objectif moi je crois que
et pourtant je l'aime bien que Vincent
payant s'est trompé
ça c'est question je pense que la
question des rythmes c'est une question
qu'il fallait si on la traitait la
prendre d'abord par l'année et donc la
question des vacances et la question des
semaines et pas simplement la question
de la journée puisque vous le savez
probablement la France et le pays en
Europe où il y a le plus de vacances etc
donc bon on aurait dû le prendre
globalement deuxièmement je pense que
l'éducation nationale elle a une urgence
un problème vitale urgent qui devrait
être prioritaire c'est que aujourd'hui
il y a 40 % de jeunes qui rentrent en 6e
sont maîtriser pour les uns ou ne
sachant pas lire et écrire pour les
autres ceci n'est pas admissible dans
l'école de la République vous avez vu la
difficulté de faire rentrer les
professeurs les mettre en agricole à la
fin du mois plutôt que mon avis je vous
l'ai donné et je pense que la priorité
c'est d'apprendre à tous nos enfants et
à tous les enfants de la République
française à maîtriser la lecture et
l'écriture donc est-ce qu'il faut que la
droite notamment à Paris accompagne
peut-être
c'est une question qu'on ne peut plus
est-ce que vous vous rendez compte qu'on
a en France aujourd'hui 150 000 jeunes
qui sortent de notre école chaque année
sans aucune formation alors moi je dis
ça vaudrait le coup d'avoir un contrat
sur cinq ans 10 ans 15 ans avec toutes
les forces politiques françaises pour
dire on en finit avec tout ça et on
refait une école digne de ce nom
à tout le monde sur le plan européen
vous avez des propositions en matière
d'apprentissage il faut il faut
apprendre vite il faut apprendre le plus
tôt possible il faut faire la
remédiation quand l'enfant est petit il
faut renforcer les encadrements dès le
début évidemment en primaire on ne peut
plus laisser aller comme ça au collège
des jeunes qui ne maîtrisent pas
l'essentiel pour eux dans la vie
française
je vous donne absolument raison sur ce
point là je pense exactement ça je pense
qu'il faut du temps pour remonter notre
école il faut les objectifs et que ces
objectifs de votre commun alors il y a
une personnalité de l'UMP qui a fait
entendre sa voix sur les questions
européennes c'est Henri Guaino il est à
l'opposé de ce que vous pensez
aujourd'hui il a déposé à l'Assemblée
une proposition de résolution pour
réclamer la suspension des poursuites
judiciaires qui ont été engagés à son
encontre pour outrage à magistrat
comment comment jugez-vous cette
démarche d'un député
je pense que là on est vraiment dans le
mélange des genres où on est jugé partis
chacun ou le parlementaire s'occupe de
la justice qui lui est faite écouter les
sons faire les choses et faisons
confiance à la justice
sur le magistrat dans l'affaire
bétoncourt
des européennes on parle beaucoup d'une
intervention possible de Nicolas Sarkozy
ça vous semble opportun ou pas
vous n'avez pas reconnu parmi les grands
européens tout à l'heure non je pense
qu'il est européen Sarkozy mais comme
François Hollande est européen mais je
fais une différence entre être européen
être un grand Européen et je fais une
différence entre visionnaire porter une
vision si au fond vous demandez à
Sarkozy ou à Hollande quelle est votre
vision à 5 ans 10 ans 15 années de
l'Europe je ne suis pas du tout sûr
qu'ils aient quelques idées tout cela
qu'est-ce que la France doit attendre de
cette Europe je suis pas du tout sûr
qu'ils aient quelques idées en tous les
cas ils en ont pas fait part vraiment en
français alors Nicolas Sarkozy au moment
de la crise il a plutôt géré pas mal
en liaison et bien avec Gordon Brown qui
avait un certain nombre d'idées pour la
sortie de la crise on aurait pu gérer
mieux d'ailleurs et plus vite parce que
ça a pas été si formidable que ça et je
pense que François Hollande a un
problème sur l'Europe c'est que le
premier secrétaire du PS se souvient du
référendum qu'il a fait et de ses
contradictions à l'intérieur de sa
majorité mais pour l'UMP c'est la même
chose à partir du moment où il y a des
contradictions dans ces deux grands
partis ça les empêche d'être au fond
clairement européen en tant que par le
meurtre européenne est-ce que vous
estimez normal cette transhumance
mensuel entre Bruxelles et Strasbourg
et net qu'à Strasbourg je serai encore
plus heureux si c'est ça à votre
question parce que moi je considère que
c'est formidable que le Parlement
européen soit à Strasbourg éloigné que
d'autres décisions
que la question de la réconciliation
franco-allemande oui c'est un symbole et
que je préfère un parlement à Strasbourg
plutôt qu'à Bruxelles
merci beaucoup merci Perrine bonsoir
madame de sarnaise à très vite demain
notre invité Perrine sera l'UMP Laurent
Wauquiez qui a fait aussi entendre une
voix dissonante qui vous déplaît sur
l'Europe
ont été fortement débattus et contestés
par les euros enthousiastes comme vous
pouvez avoir la thèse bonsoir